they say great things come in small  packages and 1959 for the launch of a  very small car that became a design icon  the brainchild of British designer Alec  is a gonis designed as a car that was  cheap to buy cheap to run and spacious  the formula proved popular the mini is  the best-selling British car in history  despite its success the manufacturers  struggled automaker BMC was said to lose  30 pounds on each sale in 1994 it was  bought under the name Rover white BMW  but by 1999 Rover was a liability and  BMW sold it but it kept one thing the  MINI brand the last original Mini rolled  off the production line in two thousand  one year later BMW launched their  version of the mini purist said it was  too big too loud and too different but  it's sold now the modern mini makes up  fifteen percent of BMWs vehicle sales in  almost 14 years into the new generation  company has just produced its three  millionth car quite an adventure